ben
[Alkış]
size buraya bir whatla geldim
size zamanı nasıl dolduracağınız ı
öğretmeni var ediyorum
biyolojik olarak
zamanınızı dondurmayı
dolayısıyla da gençlik sürenizi uzatmayı
vadediyorum uzatılmış bir gençlik hangi
kadın bunu istemez
genç bir kadın figürü dediğimiz zaman
aklımıza canlandır sanız nasıl bir şey
düşünürsünüz
kum saati gibi ince bir verdiğim zaten
Oyunca Belin Sırrı da kum saatinin
kullarının
akışına bağlı okullar bittiği zaman saat
gibi ben masa saati gibi olmaya
başlamıyorum kiloda
bu sayıldıktan şişmanlıktan
bahsetmiyorum genç hücreler biyolojik
olarak o bile öyle yapmaya o ciddi o
şekilde gergin tutmaya zaten ki dediler
ama zaman ilerledikçe
biyolojimi zamana yenildikçe o gücü
kaybediyorlar görünen o ki gençlik
zamanla
kolay kaybedilen bir şeymiş gibi
görünüyor ama aslında öyle mi biyolojik
zaman kronolojik zamanla paralel
Keşke gerçekten zamanı dolduracak bir
şey olsa durdurmak deniyorum bir şekilde
zaman akacak ama bir sürü için
dondurursak askıya alsak yavaşlat Sak Ne
bileyim böyle bir zaman kapsülü gibi
birşey olsa da onun içine girsek
dışarıdakiler için zaman geçerken bizim
için daha az geçse biyolojik olarak ama
biz bunu sadece aramızda düşünüyoruz
bunu bilim adamları da düşünüyor Neden
Çünkü
evden mantıklı ekibinin Mars'a gidip
gelebilmesi iki yıl alacak ama uzaydaki
şartlar insan biyolojisine Uygun
olmadığı için bizi çok hızlı
yaşlandırıcı ağında o iki yılda uzay
yolcuları 20 yaşa kadar hızlı yaşlanacak
lar bunu çözmek zorunda var o yüzden de
işte bu filmlerde gördüğünüz gibi
kapsüllerde biyoloji yavaşlatmayı
düşünüyorlar zaten iki seçenekleri var
ya böyle bir kapsül olacak o kapsülün
içerisindeki ortam biyoloji hücresel
yaşlanmayı yavaşlatacak ki o sırayı
geçebilirler veya mu kaktüslerin içinde
olduğu uzay araçları bu Işık hızına
yakın hareket edebilecek gidip gelirken
zamanı alt etsin ölümü fizik kuralı var
biliyoruz değil mi birşey hızı bu Işık
hızına yaklaştıkça o şey için zaman
yavaşlar zamanın göreceliği kuralım
şimdi onu ya O çok zor o yüzden bu
kapsül üstüne çalışıyorlar ve kafa
yoruyorlar Biz diyorlar insanlar nasıl
böyle bir şeyin içerisine tutabiliriz ne
gibi şartlar lazım filmlerde
hatırladığımız kadarıyla Bir de
Gördüğünüz üzere bu kapsüllerde ki
Şartlar ne
uzay Yolcuları uyuyorlar yemek
yemiyorlar su içiyorlar Karanlıkta ve
soğukta ortamda var şimdi İnsan
fizyolojisinin buna uygun olup olmadığı
yani burada yavaşlamış olan biyolojinin
insanlar uygun olup olmadığını
araştırmak için de dünyada zaten bu
zaman kapsülünde olan canlılara
bakıyorlar dünyada zaman karşısında olan
canlılar var Biz olarak gider Latif
hayvanlar diyoruz kış uykusuna yatan
hayvanlar aslında bir tür zaman kalpsiz
içindeler bu aracı kendi zaman
kapsülünde bütün dışı geçiriyor
borç şimdi psikoloji olarak bunları ele
alıyorlar uzayda hareket edebilmek için
Çünkü bu hayvanlar bu şekildeyken bu
için halindeyken metabolizma ların pası
tuşuna basıyorlar nabızları ya başlıyor
nefes alışları yavaşlıyor vücut ısısını
düşüyor metabolizma yavaşlıyor
yani sonuçta bütün sistemlerin o zaman
geçirmeye göre yavaşlamış oluyor ama
baktığımız zaman bu hayvanları da
temelin hangi şartlar altında olduğundan
bir bakıyoruz uykuda yemiyor içmiyor
Karanlıkta ve soğukta
larç şimdi biliyoruz ki bu hayvanlar
aylarca yemeden orada duruyorlar işte
ayıcık ne yapıyor Aslı kendi yağlarını
yapıyor Değil mi bu kadarını biliyoruz
ama hiç düşündünüz mü Bunlar suda
içiyorlar nasılsınız yaşıyorlar aylarca
ya o yağlarını yakarken her yağ
yandığında biyolojik olarak yanında da
su çıkar
Baro yüzden bundan yağlarını yakarken
bir yandan suda elde etmiş oluyorlar
çöldeki denemelerde öyle örgülerinde su
yok ki ya var Onu yapıyorlar bardağı
iste bu çocuklar yağ ve suyu yaptıkları
yerden yakarak elde ediyorlar niye bunu
yapıyorlar diye temelde baktığımızda da
asla bu hayvanların 13 saatleri olduğunu
görüyoruz Bu hayvanlarda mevsimleri
ayarlı olarak biyolojik saatler var ve o
biyolojik iş saatinde Güneş ışığının
miktarı belirliyor yazdan Kışa
geçirdiğinde ne şaşırır miktarı azaldığı
zaman bu hayvanların metabolizmaları
sadece yağ yakmaya dönüyor gibi
hayvanların güneş ışığı azaldığından
akışkan halindeki metabolizmaları
karbonhidrat yapmıyor sadece yağ yakıyor
sistemleri böyle ve o yanarken de tabii
ki yanında çıkan suyla susuz yemeksiz o
zaman atıyorlar tombik böyle olarak
giriyor Fikri olarak çıkıyor yattığı
yerden özellik değil mi Keşke biz de
öyle yapabilsek Keşke bizim de
hibernasyon umuz ne bileyim uyku kapsülü
müz zaman kapsülünü olsa belki de var
mı acaba Biz her gece bir tür biber
Nasyonal atıyor olabilir miyiz uyku
bizim bir zaman kapsülü olabilir mi mi
temelde Kış uykusunda uyku binasına çok
benziyor Sana uyku biraz daha onu yüzey
şöyle bir gerekçesi aynı Uykunu da
gerekçesi saatler iç saatler bizim saat
şaka yapmış saatlerimiz tık o
hayvanlardaki güneşe ayarlı olarak
çalışıyor Onlarınki mevsimsel bizimkisi
Gece de gündüz ayarında
gündüz Işık varken sistem başka gece
ışık azaldığında başka
ve asla gözümüzü açtığımız ilk anda o
saatler kuruluyor sabah de ilk gün
ışığıyla tam geceki uyku yarımız
belirleniyor Yani aslında uyumaya
sabahtan ayarlıyoruz
bu
benzerlikte daha farklı yerde bütün
ayrıntılar da benzer Biz de biber motif
armağanlar gibi o sırada uyku halindeyiz
yemiyoruz iç bu vücut ısımız normalden
düşük ve karanlıktayız en azından
Gözümüz kapalı olduğu için uykuda
olduğumuzu çıkar anlatayım yani temel
fizyoloji birbirine benziyor benzerlik
bununla da bitmiyor
Bizim bu da yakıyoruz Üstelik bizim
okulda yapmamız da iç saatler yüzünden
baştan ayarları Güneş azaldığı andan
itibaren tüm metabolizma lütfen
karbonhidrat değil ya ayak diyo buna
mecburuz uykuda Aslında biz de o
hayvanlar gibi yaptığımız yerden
yapıyoruz üstelikte o yağlar okul saati
masa saati yapan kötü yağlar bel karın
iç organ bölgesindeki istenmeyen yağlar
bütün gece yakılan yağlar var yağlar
yansımayı başka avantaj da var yanında
bütün yaşlı hücrelerde yok ediliyor
otofaji diyoruz o top aşı kendi kendini
yemek demek biz Gece uykudayken ve açken
vücuttaki eski yaşlı hücreleri vücut
deyip yok ediyor bu yaptığın yerden
zayıfladım eski hücrelerinden kurtulduk
gençlere yer açtım Eskiler gitme denir
gelmiyor hücrelerin iki tane süper
avantaj üstü gece yatarken su içmiyor
seni 8 saat çok değil ama susuz
kalıyoruz acaba Hayır bizdede gece yağ
yakarken Aslında su çıkıyor her bir gram
ya için bir o kadar miktarda su yağ
yakılırken yanında Bonus çıkıyor daha da
iyisi biz o suyu metabolik su diyoruz
Daha iyi bir suyu o suyun vücudu
temizlediği nemlendir dihidrat ettiği
kadar güçlü bir şey yok metabolik Su
Bizim vücudumuz için en iyisinin yaptık
göbek yağlarını seyrettik eski
hücrelerden kurtulduk Bir de vücudumuzun
evlendirdik uykunun işte uykudaki
açlığın üstüne bir sürü konuşmalar
yapabiliriz bütün hastalıkları iyi etmek
işte inflamasyonu azaltmak
depresyonu daha iyi gelmekle gibi bir
sürü konuyu birbirine bağladığınızda Hoş
geldiniz bu sistemi bizi Aslında gündüz
yaşlandığımızı gece geriye çevirmeye
yönelik olduğunu ve Aslında gerçekten de
uyku konumunda olanların birçok zaman
kapsülü zamanı dondurma askıya almakla
ilgili bir zaman kapsülü olduğunu
anlıyoruz ben gerçekten de o sırada
metabolizmamız da ufak bir fazla oluyor
Ve geriye doğru sarıyor buraya kadar
olanları bir sürü yerde ben de konuştum
başkaları da söyledim Vakıf ben size a
oda daha fazlasını fark ettim dedim ki
zamanı dondurmayı takacağım biliyorum
paylaşacağım şimdi zamanında olabilmesi
için fizik kuralına geri dönelim ne
demiştik zor zamanın göreceliği fizikte
şöyle açıklanıyor bir şey hızı Işık
hızına yaklaşıyorsa o şey için zaman
yavaşlar
bir şey çok kazanması lazım haklı olmuş
şimdi gördüm olarak kızına mıyız çünkü
büyük
ulaşamayız zaten uykudayız bütün
metrobüse buraya bu nefesinize başlamış
lazım diye başladı bizim için herşeyi
zaten yavaşlamış Ama bizim için de bir
şey çok hızlanmış olması lazım Benim
haklı olduğum için o zaman demek ki o
şey çok küçük çok hafif bir şey olmasa
ben biyolojik dünyada olayları takip ede
ede ede edip olarak atomu seviyesindeki
düzeyine gelirsem ancak cevabını
bulabilirim o zaman vücudun içinde diğer
olmalı o yerde olaylar atomaltı seviyede
olmalı ve bu adama seviyede atom
parçacıklarından birinde ışık hızıyla
yarışabilir kıza gelebilmesi söz konusu
olması lazım buçukta böyle bir şey var
bende Teknik olarak haklı olmuş oluyor
acaba var bir
elektron Transport zinciri çok Komplike
gibi geliyor ismi ama çok basit Çünkü
günlük hayatımızın en temel parçasından
biri bizim mitokondri dediğimiz enerji
ürettiğimiz yollar ca0 ve her tarafında
her cisimde olan organel cidden içinde
bir bölüm bu bölüm ATP'nin Yani bizim
canlarımızın kaynağı olan enerjinin
oluştuğu yer ve enerjide elektron lardan
oluşuyor
elektronlar nereden geliyor
yiyeceklerden Ne yersek yiyelim hiç fark
etmez Ne yediğimiz ister sağlık ister
sağlıksız Sonuçta ondan elde ettiğiniz
şey elektron lan o elektronlar bu
zincirin üstünde Akara ATP oluyorlar
zaten bakın zincirin Adalet transform
zinciri ve normal vücudunuz içindeki bir
olaydan bahsediyorum protein
Transformers zincir deniyorum
karbonhidrat Transport incir deniyor ya
francfort zincir demiyorum elektron
Transport zincir diyorum Çünkü orada
elektron Ankara Maltepe oluyorlar şimdi
bilgi bu işte vücudun içerisindeki
sayısı sayıdaki elektron Transport
zincirinden akan elektronların hızı
yavaş bir yaşam hızını belirleyen şey
Eğer bunları hızlandırabilir sekeer
Bunları hep ideal Rıza akıllarını
sağlayabilir Seiko zaman zamanda boş
ederiz
çok Ne yaptılar Aslında elektronların
bildiğiniz anlamda değil de kuantum
tünelleme denen bir yöntemle aklında
araştırıp öğrenebilirler bu kavramlar
İşte o bahsettiğin ışık hızıyla
yarışmaya uygun kavramları da gerçekten
de işler orada böyle dönüyor Biz şöyle
düşünelim madem bu zincirin üstünden
elektron akışını hızı zamanı
değiştiriyor mesaj zincirin boyu
kutsalsa elektron akışını arttırıyoruz
mı mı ev teknik bilgiyi elektron
transform zincir boyu bir androma salsa
üstünden geçen elektronların akış hızı
yüzde on on kat artıyor Bu ne demek on
kat geç yaşlanıyoruz on kat yavaşlıyor
zaman biyolojik olarak ve o kat genç
kalıyoruz Bunların hepsi Teknik olarak
şimdi
ve bu kısım bilgiyi Ne yaparsınız
bilmiyorum dediğim gibi el olmasında
paylaşırsınız Olayı çözdük mi dersiniz
Buradan çıktıktan sonra internet olmaz
mısınız bilmiyorum ama bu dediğini
Günlük hayatta nasıl yapıyor vücut
dersek Şu soruyu sorabiliriz Acaba bizim
elektron akışı mızın en hızlı olduğu
dolayısı ile de aslında biyolojik olarak
zamanın içeride en yavaş geçtiği şartlar
nelerdir
uykuda
olabildiğince derin uzun süreli açlık
gün olan en soğuk odada karanlık bir
ortamda olduğunuz zaman gerçekten
elektronların akış hızı en hızlı oluyor
çünkü atacakları o zincirin boyu kısa
oluyor işte
sağlığı belirleyen ya da uzun süre geç
kalmayı belirleyen de Bize öğretilen
küçük sağlık kavramlarının altından bu
çıkıyor
bu demek ki biz Aslında Teknik olarak
kendi zaman kapsülünü yapıyoruz her gece
onu daha ideal yap o ufak ölülerimizi bu
konuya bağlayarak hatırlatalım kendi
zaman kapsülü yapmak için ideal açlık
beşten sonra yemiyoruz bunları hormonal
sirkadiyen işler gece 23'ten sonra
elektroniklerin özellikle olmak üzere
parlak ışıklara bakmıyoruz bakmak
zorundaysak kırmızı ışıklar evde
kullanıyoruz şimdi kırmızı sinyalleri
bozmuyor parlak Işıklar gibi değil gece
23.00 de Uygun salındığı saatte mutlaka
yatakta oluyoruz karanlık bir ortamda
oluyor ve yatak odasını ısıda
yapabileceğiniz En minimum kızıda oluyor
sıcak oldu bu şartları sağladığımız
zaman gece boyunca gerçekten bir
biyolojik zaman kapsülünde oluyoruz ve
yavaşlıyor yaşlanmanın ve iyileşme miz
gençleşmenin bütün tamirleri mizi
artıyor
Dolayısıyla E ben size vadettiğim hem
uzamış gençliği biyolojik olarak
anlattım ha ve fizik olarak anlattım
Umarım faydalı oldum